Speaker 1: All right, I have some extraordinarily
disturbing video to play for you, this is
a new interview with, again, I guess, former
Trump fraud lawyer Sydney Powell.
You might remember that whether she was even
Trump's lawyer is like a subject of debate.
She was having meetings in the Oval Office,
which certainly signals a connection to Donald
Trump.
At the same time, the Trump campaign at one
point put out a statement when she went really
bonkers, saying she's working on her own.
We still don't really have answers to that.
But she's delivered some very strange interviews
recently.
Sydney Powell has now given an interview in
which she drags Supreme Court Justice Samuel
Alito into the January 6th mess.
The claim that she makes is that part of the
point of the January 6th riots was to delay
things enough that Samuel Alito would be able
to intervene and somehow give the election
to Trump.
I mean, you know how these things are.
It's always like, well, exactly how it's not
clear.
She gave an interview on the STO Peters show.
This is not a program I'm familiar with.
But her claim, if she's right, this is the
most extreme premeditated criminality, including
the highest levels of power that maybe we've
ever seen.
If she's making it up, she probably needs
a psych eval.
I mean, I don't you know, to be totally honest,
I don't really know which of the two it is.
But let's take a look at this.
Here is the interview.
Let's listen to Sydney Powell.
The audio quality is terrible.
The video quality is terrible.
But let's do our best to to try to really
understand what it is she's claiming here.
Speaker 3: Heard on untold election case.
Speaker 4: Yes, we were filing a Twelfth Amendment
constitutional challenge to the process that
the Congress was about to use under the Electoral
Act, provisions that simply don't jive with
the 12th Amendment to the United States Constitution.
And Justice Alito was our circuit justice
for that.
Louie Gohmert was the plaintiff in our lawsuit.
And we were suing the vice president to follow
the 12th Amendment as opposed to the Electoral
Count Act.
So our Electoral College Act.
So that was the the main point.
And Nancy Pelosi had finagled to file an amicus
brief in it.
There had been inside goings on in Congress
whereby I believe it was Steve Scalise and
McCarthy kept her from being an actual party.
She wanted to work our way into the case of
the party, but somehow, politically, that
didn't happen.
But she got notice when we made our filing
because she wanted to file an amicus brief
or had filed an amicus brief.
Speaker 1: And then if you're confused, I
mean, the guy on the left looks as confused
as as you and I probably are.
I'll try to explain what she's talking about
in a second.
Although, again, if these are just her delusions,
it really there is no explanation.
Speaker 4: Everything broke loose and she
had to really speed up reconvening Congress
to get the vote going before Justice Alito
might have issued an injunction to stop at
all, which is what should have happened.
Speaker 1: OK, so.
The gist of what she seems to be saying here
is that the idea of the riot was to create
a delay so that you could get a particular
amicus or, as she says, amicus brief to the
Supreme Court with the idea that Samuel Alito
again, I'm trying to interpret what a crazy
person saying, but the idea is Samuel Alito
would be able to do something and then Trump
becomes president, I guess, or something like
that.
But they didn't anticipate that Nancy Pelosi
would so quickly reconvene on January 6th,
late, really early January 7th.
It was kind of the middle of the night, you
know, technically January 7th for much of
it and move forward.
And that's what interfered with this now.
If this is true.
And Alito knew that this was the expectation
or, you know, part said, OK, I mean, it would
be an incredible conspiracy at the absolute
highest level.
It would have all been premeditated.
If Powell is to be believed, Samuel Alito
should be impeached, OK?
It also might just be completely made up.
And I'm going to be very honest with you.
It almost seems more likely to me.
I mean, Sidney Powell lies all the time and
she might be making all of this up.
And that's its own problem.
And that would be one possibility.
Now, the third possibility is she believes
this stuff, but it's not true.
Like she's actually delusional.
And if that's the case, you're really talking
psych eval.
I mean, I'm going to be totally frank that
that's what it is.
So if what she says is true, it would be grounds
for impeaching Samuel Alito.
Potentially, if it's a lie, then she's really
a crazy liar who's willing to just make up
anything.
And if she believes it, but it's completely
imaginary.
It's kind of a sad mental health sort of situation.
Let's go to one more clip.
This is this is funny because this is now
the interviewer and I'm trying to figure out,
like, what is he he's trying to explain what
Cydney Powell, I guess, said.
And it's like it's even more confusing.
Speaker 3: Let's listen up the Q why Nancy
Pelosi had to hurry on January 6th.
According to Powell, on the very day of January
6th, there was a one last ditch legal effort
that might have stopped the certification
of disputed electoral states by the Congress,
a legal challenge to the Electoral Count Act,
a one hundred and thirty year old law that
governs the actual Electoral College process.
Now, this law gives both the House and Senate
explicit roles in evaluating electoral slates,
even though the 12th Amendment to the Constitution
only gives the House a role in choosing the
president.
Speaker 1: OK, so this is a part of what they've
been pushing, which is we need only the house
should be picking the president like the Senate
shouldn't even have been involved on January
six.
This is another one of these.
It's sort of like if I misspell my name, I'm
not taxable.
Like that was a whole movement.
It's that type of movement.
And Stu Peters seems to be sort of sort of
explaining that
Speaker 3: the Senate, as we know, is only
involved in choosing a vice president.
Right.
So Powell brought a lawsuit to overturn that
law, but only filed at the afternoon of January
2nd.
Bunch of people were trampling,
Speaker 1: would have been something to think
about sooner through
Speaker 3: the capital and what later would
be referred to as the great insurrection.
Yeah.
Now, that insurrection might have played to
her advantage by delaying the final resolution
of the election.
But then Nancy Pelosi won Opta by reconvening
Congress and finishing the tally in the middle
of the night.
The next day, Supreme Court Justice Alito
dismissed the case, but according to Powell,
it might have been different if that election
wasn't already over.
Speaker 1: So I guess he's just explaining
he keep.
If if I'm understanding him correctly, my
understanding of what Sydney Powell is claiming
is accurate, it doesn't make what Sydney Powell
is claiming any more true.
So who knows what the truth is?
Maybe Powell increasingly thinks she's going
down and she's seeing who can who can I take
down with me if I implicate Alito?
Maybe it helps me in some way.
The bigger picture is the more we learn, the
more premeditated this might have been on
January 6th, allegedly involving more and
more parties.
Whether any individual claim is true, honestly,
I don't know, because the people involved
are so dishonest.
Rudy, John Ellis, Sydney Powell, Trump himself,
Bannon.
You know, if these people had their way, the
US would be a complete and total theocracy,
an utter authoritarian Christian theocracy.
That's actually what we're fighting against
here.